we take the shear
endless possibilities that we have at
our disposal for granted our world is
changing the new generation of today is
growing up in a way that is completely
different from anything that we've
experienced in the past we ourselves
forget that we once grew up with
technology
although primitive it was all around us
this is especially true if you're a kid
of the 1980s or 1990s today we're all
connected and the entire world is at our
fingertips we can reach out to whoever
we want whenever we want it's all
changing very fast isn't it but where
did it come from
and where is it going right now we're at
the very start of an overhaul of our
modern world the subsequent events that
you're about to learn all come together
to form one of the greatest stories ever
told
let me take you on a journey to a time
when things were simple
the very style of our story has humble
beginnings but it's absolutely
incredible when you think about it
it's amazing how many people don't
actually know how it all began here we
go
for most of humanity a computer was
actually a person that carried out
complex calculations pretty much all day
one of these computers was Charles
Babbage in the early 1820s Babbage is
getting pretty annoyed because he kept
finding mistakes in his log tables there
were cases of ships screwing up and
running aground because there are
mistakes in the navigation tables there
needed to be a solution and he was the
first to ask well if physical machines
can do physical work
why can't physical machines do mental
work and not just any mental work but a
general-purpose
kind of mental work and with that simple
thought the idea of the computer as we
know it was born fast-forwarding a bit
through time we find themselves in the
1930s wasn't it all a rosy tie and by
any standards we had the Great
Depression the rise of Hitler the
Hindenburg disaster wasn't all bad
though it said that during the toughest
times we sometimes come up with the
greatest inventions this next piece of
the story is the stuff of legend enter
the German gentlemen Konrad Zuse
you could loosely say that he is the
inventor of the computer while slaving
away doing some engineering calculations
Zeus had a vision what if you could get
a machine to do the work for him an
automatic computer
so this believed in his idea of the
computer so much that he quit his job
and moved back into his parents place
just to build it he saw that human
computers just used ten numbers and a
few symbols when you move them around
you got the result that you want it how
do you simplify that the answer binary
just ones and zeroes it can't get any
simpler this thinking was so brilliant
that we still use his solution today to
utilize the form of ones and zeros he
decided to use mechanical switches but
there was a problem every switch had to
be perfect or else the whole thing
wouldn't work there needed to be a
better way the answer came in the form
of magnetic telephone switches once he
had completed his work he decided to
test it he fed in a complex problem and
it worked and this was the very
beginning well why did he do it who
better to explain it than himself this
is an interview with him in 1992 where a
young person clearly has better things
to do than study and calculate you could
say that I was too lazy to calculate and
so I invented the computer what an
awesome guy the pioneer of our modern
world invented the computer because he
was lazy let's continue on traveling a
little bit further the story continues
in the middle of the war in the 1940s
even though Konrad Zuse is computer was
the stuff of genius the use of relay
switch has made a to slow to really be
of any use
that's why people in the 40s look to
vacuum tubes as the way of the future
during the heat of World War two the US
military had human computers calculate
the angle of which missile should be
fired different weather conditions it
took sixty three thousand hours of human
brain power just to complete one
flowering table for one weather
condition as you could guess there
weren't enough people for the job there
must have been a better way but what
could it be
two guys John Mark Lee and jr. card had
the solution
ENIAC a computer composed of 18,000
vacuum tubes the crazy part vacuum tubes
were notorious for blowing up
so the scoffing experts calculated that
the machine would break down every five
seconds but the army was so desperate
that they went ahead with funding anyway
and it worked they pulled it off we'll
skip the details that basically they
utilized a very clever design they would
ensure the machine kept working if one
of the parts happen to fail here's a fun
fact
since ENIAC couldn't actually store
anything in order to change a program
you had to rewire the entire system with
a team of people this usually took days
well how do we go about changing a
program today easy just double click or
tap
ENIAC was groundbreaking because was the
first ever electric general-purpose
computer even though the electric
computer was a brilliant idea there was
a large amount of social acceptance lay
people take years to get used to or
comfortable with new ideas nobody knew
what to use the computer for so not many
people took notice at all it was said
that the entire USA would only ever need
eight computers ever let's take a look
at the moment when this all changed 1951
this is when the computer went public
universe
the first commercial computer was asked
to predict the outcome of the u.s.
presidential election okay speaking to
you from CBS television election
headquarters there in New York City
let's turn to that miracle of the modern
age the electronic brain univac and
charles collingwood this is not a joke
or a trick it's an experiment we think
it's going to work we don't know we hope
it'll work what resulted was absolute
chaos UNIVAC predicted that there will
be a landslide victory for eisenhower
but there's so much acceptance lag that
nobody believed the results how could
something predict the outcome with only
5% of the votes
it turns out that univac was right to
within 3%
that must have scared the hell out of
people because people began to get
scared of the electronic brains he's
trying to replace us all with a
mechanical brain that means the end of
his own that clip may look hilarious now
but back then it was a legit concern
people are actually being replaced by
computers but they are still huge though
and the culprit
that dodgy vacuum tube but it was soon
going to be replaced by something that
was a fiftieth of the size was a hundred
times lighter and still used a fraction
of the power it was called the
transistor one of the greatest
inventions of the 20th century let's
step things up a little bit we'll take a
stroll through time into the 1960s the
story really begins to gain momentum now
all that stuff before was just child's
play strap yourselves in for a few
surprises the 1960s were a time of
change some notable characters later on
in the story got their inspiration from
the spirit of the 60s the 60s were a
jumble of the counterculture Vietnam War
moon-landing some revolutionary music
and many events which would change the
course of history forever
finally people were free computers no
longer had to be the size of rooms so
they could be more powerful and do much
more stuff and also be smaller
unfortunately connecting thousands of
transistors met thousands of wires and
circuit boards were just a jumbled mess
and it was almost impossible to do this
was solved with the invention of the
integrated circuit soon many transistors
could just be printed onto circuit
boards you would think that this
invention would open the floodgates for
innovation or and wonder but no once
again there was acceptance lag and
nobody used the invention this all
quickly changed when the Russians were
the first to enter space this push
President Kennedy to make affirmative
action NASA needed to get an American
crew of astronauts into space I believe
that this nation should commit itself to
achieving the goal before this decade is
out of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to the earth but
that wasn't possible with a one-ton
computer NASA soon stumbled across the
integrated circuit and they began to
utilize it looking back on it today that
was a real turning point it was the real
start of the modern age of computing we
managed to send man into space to the
moon and return him safely back to earth
it was a real triumph for the whole of
humanity and it wouldn't have been
possible without the integrated circuit
but just for a comparison today as
high-end smartphones are over 2,200
times faster with over three million
times the memory of the NASA Apollo 11
guidance computer the first integrated
circuit had 10 transistors and cost
$10,000 over time things obviously
changed and it was the fastest change in
history to be exact
today our chips have billions of
transistors that's why we have so much
power
so we're about to move into the 1970s
but before we do let's take a look at
two revolutionary ideas that should have
changed the world as we know it but
didn't because the level of acceptance
lag was just too damn high
the first one was sketchpad a
revolutionary drawing program that was
invented in 1960 the point to note here
was that it was the software that was
the breakthrough the hardware was still
that big old clunky computer that people
thought was for number crunching moaning
button and the amazing thing to me is
that this did not start a vast movement
in fact it just stood there's an example
that people would gaze at they look at
the move you'd say yeah gee well that's
very inspirational and they'd go back
and do exactly what they were doing
probably the most baffling area of this
story was Douglass Engelberg he was by
far the biggest visionary of the
computer industry not Steve Jobs Douglas
Engelbart the acceptance lag level was
over 9000 in a spectacular 1968 demo he
showed us the invention of the mouse
hyperlinked text the precursor to email
and the very beginnings of the graphical
user interface the same technology that
we love and use every single day
generally when I tried a mouse and it
was too hard to use it never worked
it's kind of trying to wake people to
the potential of which this is just
scratching the surface of what's really
there to help people think and work
together
sadly Douglas Engelbert passed away just
before the recording of this program I'm
sure that he will be happy that billions
of people use his inventions every day
as we move into the 1970s the pace of
change absolutely explodes
the culprit the 1971 invention of the
microprocessor by a little company
called Intel now for the first time
thousands of transistors can be on a
single chip it set a chain of events in
motion that were still seeing the
effects of today just how fast will the
change is happening let's find out he is
if the auto industry had moved at the
same speed our industry your car today
would cruise comfortably at a million
miles an hour probably get a half a
million miles per gallon of gasoline but
it would be cheaper to throw away your
rolls-royce and buy a new one to the
park at downtown for the evening
the microchip caused an explosion in the
industry and most companies amalgamated
around the San Francisco Bay Area
there's later to be dubbed Silicon
Valley a printer company names Knox
built off the platform of Engel Bert's
work they built the personal computer as
we know it today
in 1973 over 10 years before anyone else
but they couldn't see a reason why
anyone with one one so they didn't
market it yep they had the future and
they just let it sit there but we'll
come back to this Xerox had the mindset
of most companies at the time one of
such companies was IBM they were very
happy using massive mainframe computers
but for the life of them they could not
understand why people would want a
personal computer but as it turns out
people did want a personal computer
people just dreamed of what they could
do if they had all of this power to
themselves here we meet one of three
major influential characters in this
story Steve wasn't yet I found the mini
computer with 4k of RAM cost as much as
a house I told my father I've decided
that someday I'm going to have an
apartment instead of a house I'm going
to buy myself a computer I'm gonna be
the one person that owns a computer
Steve Wozniak was friends with our
second character Steve Jobs since the
age of 14 though always known to build
little technical projects together so
building a computer with a newfound
microchip wasn't that big of a leap
Steve Wozniak wanted his own computer so
badly he built one for himself and that
was it
he just wanted it for himself but Steve
Jobs saw the potential
he saw that everyone could have
something like this and everyone would
want it he saw what IBM and Xerox
couldn't see he saw a product contrary
to popular belief neither of them knew
how to run a business they probably
would have ended up flat on their faces
and collapsing like all the other
startup companies in the day they needed
someone to guide them they turned to
Mike Markkula
and the two guys really didn't have the
background and experience to to start a
company and make it successful so I
agreed to help
soon after the collaboration with Mike
the Apple 2 was released
remember nobody really knew what to use
the personal computer for most of the
public didn't even know what a personal
computer was the Apple 2 needed some
software that would win the masses
physique out it was the first electronic
spreadsheet just think about it before
this if you're in business you'd have to
sit there for hours doing numerous
calculations by hand and you weren't
allowed to make a mistake
it blew people's minds I was showing up
all around here and he started shaking
into that's what I do all week I could
do it in an hour I could do it you know
you know and they would take their
credit cards in trouble in your face and
sales took off Apple became the fastest
growing company in history so what had
once taken up an entire room cost
millions of dollars and weighed a ton
was now flying off the shelves in droves
IBM took notice and they eventually made
their own version of the PC IBM went on
to dominate the market and it was our
third character that helped them do that
his name was Bill Gates
let's move on to the 80s this is where
the story really reaches its climax and
a huge battle for market supremacy
emerges the 1980s in the 1980s flaunting
wealth power and technology was there
anything to do
so personal computers that gave business
users the advantage and the edge just
went crazy
in the early 1980s PC hardware was still
extremely primitive by today's standards
this is a hard drive from around that
period to take a look at it it weighed
about 250 kilograms and cost tens of
thousands of dollars well it probably
stored all of the world's information
right nope
stored 250 megabytes that's about 19
times less than a DVD or about a third
of a CD and obviously there was no way
this was going to fit in the PC this is
a 32 gigabyte microSD card from today it
holds about 128 times the data weighs a
quarter of a gram and costs about 30 to
40 bucks in addition to the pitiful
Hardware the software was pretty bad too
and guess who wrote it
Bill Gates in a funny twist it turns out
that Bill Gates his mother actually knew
the chairman of IBM through this IBM
contracted Bill Gates to write the
software for their new PC instead of
actually writing the software Bill Gates
bought the code here acquired from
another company for $50,000 and then he
modified it now that the software was
his he sold it back to IBM and kept the
rights to his product this product was
Microsoft DOS
the early 80s was a turbulent time and
the goldrush period for the PC market
since there are so many PC manufacturers
appearing Bill Gates just noticed that
he could just sell his software to
everyone as profits went off the charts
on the other side of the fence a few
years earlier in 1979 Steve Jobs had
been invited to see the Xerox graphical
computer you know the company that built
off the work of Douglas Engelbert I
thought it was the best thing I'd ever
seen in my life now within you know 10
minutes it was obvious to me that all
computers would work like this someday
it just had no clue about a computer
what it could do and so they they just
grabbed grab defeat from the greatest
victory in the computer industry Xerox
could have owned the entire computer
industry today this york's computer
inspired Steve Jobs to make the very
first Macintosh Steve Jobs eventually
asked Gates to write the software for
the Macintosh in a move of pure
blindness Steve Jobs had just given Bill
Gates full access to the unlicensed
software for the Mac huge mistake Bill
Gates would later on betray Steve Jobs
by copying the look and feel of the
Macintosh
unfortunately Macintosh sales weren't
doing that great but Steve Jobs were
still in his own illusion bubble
thinking that the Macintosh would be a
hot seller Apple didn't agree and in a
sad twist he was fired by his own
company John Sculley broke the news and
he destroyed everything I spent 10 years
working for starting with me but that
wasn't the saddest part I would have
gladly left Apple if Apple would have
turned out like I'd wanted it to
you
in jobs as own mind the Macintosh would
change the world it did but not directly
after the loss of Steve Jobs Bill Gates
began to steal more and more from what
it seen in the Macintosh he was putting
it into a new operating system it would
be called Windows and now the war was
between Microsoft PCs and the Macintosh
a massive lawsuit erupted and things
turned thermonuclear Microsoft simply
overpowered Apple and won the court case
in 1990 with a launch of windows 3.0 all
hope was lost windows 3.0 went on to
sell three million copies in the first
year and the Mac instantly became a
niche product um and so I guess I am
saddened not by Microsoft success I have
no problem with their success they've
earned their success for the most part I
have a problem with the fact that they
just make really third-rate products
we all know how the story went it's
pretty sad
Apple slowly started dying and became
the laughingstock and the bottom rung
throughout the 90s this probably
explains why steve was so secretive and
so strict over his products in his later
life eventually the Mac was just
forgotten and it was Windows that took
center stage this was true until
something a small white and silver
rectangular box came along and changed
the fate of Apple
so close
so I can show
I can't say
hot never save me what is that sound so
heavy
say
and with that we've reached the end of
part 1 of the series and then have to
leave you guys here but before I depart
I want to talk a little bit about
something in 1973 an event occurred that
will shape our lives today and even more
so in the future it was of course the
invention of the mobile phone by Martin
Cooper
I wonder what Martin's inspiration was
it was actually Star Trek so come back
to hear that story and a lot more
there's a lot coming up on the death of
the PC part 2 only on ColdFusion TV next
time we go through the 90s 2000s 2010 we
see the rise of the Internet age Apple's
comeback and apparent decline the rise
of Samsung and of course the future you
haven't seen anything yet if you want to
see older episodes of co-efficient TV
just check out the playlist below in the
description as a side point this is a
whole lot of work this is the hardest
I've ever worked in the video I think
it's because I'm trying to prove
something to the world technology
doesn't have to be boring or lame I just
really want to show that to the world
I'm just trying to educate people
differently it's always just been
something I've wanted to do so if you
guys can help out by sharing it over
Facebook Twitter to your grandma Hunt
doesn't really matter they will just be
a great help you guys are amazing and
thanks a lot for watching through to the
very end I know the modern attention
span isn't that long see you guys have
done well as usual don't forget to rate
comment and subscribe and I'll see you
in the future peace
you